we're on we got
there just in
case hey guys welcome back to the Spates
water lad podcast another dance and
France preview show for you here and man
we've been talking up these
quarterfinals from the start of these
episodes and man did they deliver the
best weekend of rugby I think I can ever
remember four of the most even games you
could get unbelievable atmosphere and
all pretty much going down to the very
last play incredible weekend so good
some Heartbreakers for some of the
countries but um again while I'm here
joined by the legends sirly from sirly
talk Sport and of course Jake The Snake
Atkins I went through the picks from
last week boys I think me and you Jake
we only got one Surly I believe you got
two um so mate what did you make of the
round you're the Tipping Guru oh mate it
was just chaos wasn't it like every
straight away from that Argentina game
it was just caught us all by surprise I
think what Jimmy you had Argentina
didn't you so yeah that was the only one
I got right unbelievably it was probably
the least confident I was as well well
play but even that game was chaos right
the numbers were falling off the jerseys
oh the ri got sniper it was chaos man
the old P Piper yako Piper he couldn't
last the 80 minutes it was yeah it was
kind of that set the tone for what was
about to happen for the rest of the
weekend and like whoever said
International Rugby was dying that was
the perfect dose just to get everyone
back on board and it's great to see New
Zealand we are pretty bandwagoning when
it comes to fans and now it's just all
black fever like six weeks ago it was up
the Ws everywhere you went now it's full
ABS and the lads deserve it it's unreal
yeah man what a what a weekend and you
mentioned yako he he jumped out of it
early because man some of these other
refs who played out the ad coping it way
more than he did so um he's probably a
very very smart man but we'll get to
that first game Wales versus Argentina
2917 Wales looked like they're all over
them snake arjie hung in there and then
um ajie sort of took control in that
last
20 yeah exactly J man this game started
like a house on fire Lads didn't it like
I think both both teams we we maybe
didn't expect them to play much
attacking rugby we sort of spoke in the
preview this might be a a sort of set
piece and penalty dominated game but
like didn't end up being the case they
both came out shooting from the hips
straight away for for me the straight
away one of the first plays that we saw
was uh was Argentina they set up for an
exit they set up into like a box kick
formation um and then straight away they
like called the space in from the edge
canceled the play shifted to the edge
and and moved into a Counterattack
formation and kind of felt like a slap
around the face it wasn't something I
was expecting to to see from either of
these sides but man I was absolutely
buzzing to see it and uh the the same
from Wales we we saw them play from a
from a lot deeper than we've seen them
play at the rest of the tournament man
they were they were run in nice
attacking shape in their own half first
phase they were having a go we've not
seen them do a lot of that Dan biger was
getting the ball um back out the from
from behind the midfielders turning the
corner trying to get into that 13
Channel late departure from the backs on
the outside trying to expose Argentina
in that like 134 Channel it really
really started well um there was that
little period in the Middle where the
game sort of did go to to more what we
expected where it was a a bit of a
setpiece wrestle some penalties and
stuff but Argentina coming up big in the
end with finishing off with a lovely
intercept play from the old dog still
had enough in the legs to bolt to bolt
under the sticks yeah and what a play
and what a celebration from R after the
game man it was like a party it was like
they'd won the World Cup they were so
stoked which was cool to see what' you
make of the game suly yeah pretty much
the same as what snaky said like there
were some big momentum shifts throughout
that one I thought Wales kind of had it
wrapped up early and then Argentina
they're just one of those sides e like
if you give them a sniff they're fueled
so much by Passion and once they get
their taals up they're incredibly hard
to stop so well done to them like I've
been really critical of them throughout
this world cup so they've certainly
silenced me because they've hit their
straps at the right time I will say
though after watching that game back
compared to the others it did appear to
be the weaker of the quarterfinals but
the matchup was perfect wasn't it so it
was still a really quality game that I
enjoyed watching and yeah it's not often
that you'd get up at what 4:00 a.m. on a
Sunday morning to watch Wales Argentina
and leave it really happy with the
quality of the game so I think that's a
testament to The Clash right there mate
100% And you mentioned the quality I
think we we've sort of previewed that
two really clear um games which were um
much higher level than the others um I
think we saw that I think the games were
still really entertaining but just the
level of intensity in this next game
obviously the All Blacks versus Ireland
like you said ver against Argentina
Wales and there was a definite clear
step up and intensity and man this game
had everything so who wants to start on
this one all Island we'll go to you
sirly because what a game yeah that was
crazy like I was speaking to people
after from the moment Aaron Smith kicked
that ball in what the 77th minute I
don't think I sat down for the next hour
even after the game I was pacing around
I had tears in my eyes at the end of it
just because of the roller coaster that
it was and just I guess the relief for
the boys like we spoke about taking on
Ireland but in a quarter final like it
would be so disappointing to lose a
quarter but not lose to isands I think
it was more just relief that like we're
not going to hear this chat now about
this potentially being statistically the
worst all black team or something
despite losing to the best team in in
the world like that game had it all what
two yellow cards man we had our backs
against the wall for long periods there
it looked like there were opportunities
for the Irish every time they flung The
Ball wide I got so nervous but the boys
just dug in some massive individual
performances which I'm sure we'll get to
but what a quality game of code like I
don't think we'll see two B
quarterfinals in a World Cup possibly
ever and this one was right up there
just so proud of the works and the way
they dug in to beat a bloody good Irish
side and a lot of people are saying they
choked cuz they lost in another
quarterfinal but there's no way you
could call it that they were outstanding
as well it was just two really good
teams going at it and in the end one hit
to win and I'm glad it was the All
Blacks yeah and you're right like it so
could have gone either way like it was
literally a flip of a coin I mean if you
look at all the little key moments like
the Jordy Barrett um held up of a mall
like that's almost impossible thing to
do like how do you get under that ball
from that angle like that was an
incredible play and to think that if he
couldn't quite get his leg under that
then we probably lose that game so
there's so many little things in that
game which um obviously changed the
result and have such a big swing on it
so it was incredible but what do you
make of it um snake you're you're very
analytical what' you
say well like just I watching this game
I couldn't stop thinking like this was
just such a pleasure to watch
I I couldn't believe at times the the
level of like tactical and Technical
ability of some of the players at times
and like after the game Lads as a as a
neutral like I was feeling really
emotional and I think it was for two
reasons one and I knew this would happen
before the game even kicked off I knew
that whoever lost the game I was going
to be gutted for them at the end whether
it was Ireland had got over for the
score and stolen the win or the All
Blacks like they did managed to shut
them out in that thir 7 phase defense
set I knew whichever team lost I was
just going to be gutted for them I
really struggled to be happy for the All
Blacks CU I just felt so bad for the
Ireland guys and it would have been the
exact opposite had Ireland stolen it I
wouldn't have been happy for them I
would have been gutted for the All
Blacks just because the the neither of
these teams deserves to go home at this
stage in the tournament I just yeah and
I just I genuinely felt like quite
emotional just at like how how much of a
privilege it was to watch rugby played
at this level like the the level that
these guys are playing at physically but
but tactically technically it was it was
such a pleasure to watch and I obviously
had no vested interest in it so I can't
imagine how the Irish fans in the
stadium or you guys back home would have
felt during the game with that emotional
attachment to it as well but both teams
an absolute credit to and the fans as
well
like both the sets of fans should be
incredibly proud of these teams like I
know the Irish fans will be absolutely
gutted but when the dust set was I do
hope that they appreciate how good this
iseland team was at this tournament and
they lost in one of the best matches
I've ever watched and there's no shame
in that and I hope they welcome the boys
home as if they'd you know I know they
didn't get what they wanted but as if
they'd gone as far as they should have
done because they have nothing to be
ashamed of that Ireland team exactly
like s said they didn't choke it wasn't
they didn't not turn up for the big game
like they turned up heaps and it was
just a clash of two Titan sides and it
was it was absolutely unbelievable to
watch a neutral ads oh mate snake good
to hear you speak with so much emotion I
said you're usually the analytical guy
but look at you go like you welling up
talking about the ORS vers Island game
so w him over we won him over Jimmy we W
he's a true emotional kiwi fan that's
good stuff but there was some there's
some other huge moments in this game
obviously um the Bowden chip and Chase
which led to Lester's try the Richie Mo
show and go um Sam white lot getting
over that ball that Jackal in the last
what was it at the about 85th minute
incredible scenes who really stood out
for you sirle obviously Sam Kane Aris sa
they've been getting the accolades and
deservedly so Sam Kane was out of this
world like everyone's saying that's his
best all black performance he probably
hasn't dominated a footy field like that
since bu he under Sixers he he was all
over the place and you could tell he
just really had a point to prove you
could see it in the before the game when
they shot to him like he meant business
he was ready he yeah man there'd be some
Irish Fords with some bruisers on their
bodies as a result of Sam Kane's
shoulders then Aris sa like he's just
the complete package isn't he and those
two compliment each other so well when
they're on their game like they hunt in
a pack together 's got that skill set
where he can do a box kick on his own
try line put it out past the 22 perfect
ball flight you think it was Bloody
Aaron Smith but it was our number eight
then he can score tries better than some
Wingers plus he does the physical stuff
so well you mentioned Jordy like it's
crazy we mentioned last week this time
last year in this Irish series he was
playing fullback hadn't won the 12
jersey for the All Blacks now he's right
up there it's probably him Bundy and the
South African Midfield in terms of the
best midfielders going around in the
world at the moment um yeah you could go
through and name so many people you
mentioned white lock before like he did
that exact same thing in the Super Rugby
final right won that final breakdown at
the rck for a penalty like people think
that that stuff just happens it doesn't
happen by accident he's so experienced
he's so classy he knows exactly where to
put his body in the big stages to get
these wins and I just thought all our
tries like were so well calculated they
obviously identified back of the Irish
line out they'll deal with a prop and a
flanker so let's send Richie down that
Channel with his speed a beautiful pass
off Aaron Smith he's already outside the
prop straight through the Gap like
everything was so well put together from
both sides to be fair and I thought they
executed their plans perfectly it was
just a great 80 minutes of footy and you
could almost can't pick anyone out for
not having a good game even the young
props came on and like one scrum penalty
straight away when there was so many
questions around to Mighty Williams at
International level like yeah it was
just outstanding you could go on for
hours but yeah 100% I I agree no I don't
think any of the side had a bad game
like even like you mentioned the bench
Anton L Brown coming on on the wing made
some really great reads on D when they
when the All Blacks needed it cuz they
were it was like still I know I said it
in the preview that was my biggest
concern was at all blacks edgd and it
was still giving me shivers throughout
that whole game I felt like Island
missed a fe few opportunities to play
out the back I felt like they tried to
play the front ball probably a little
bit too many times but I still felt like
our Edge d as passive as it was um we
did Bloody well to scramble I think Sam
Kane came across a couple of times to
save the day when they did make a few
breaches down there but um you don't
want to be giving that many
opportunities to the Irish team but they
obviously did and I mean that last phase
I think Ireland was so gassed after 37
phases that sort of run out of any zap
to um to get any sort of decent Hardline
down but um it's a Rugby World Cup World
Record 37 phases five minutes 19 ball in
play that last phase so what a way to
finish a rugby game is absolutely
incredible what' you make of Island um
snake I think um you make a really good
point Jim in terms of on the edge like
New Zealand were I know you hate it New
Zealand were quite passive on that edge
but they were happy to allow Ireland to
sort of throw that when Ireland did take
the opportunities to play out the back
and go wide they were happy to let
Ireland have that long loopy ball over
the top and back themselves to connect
and recover on the inside and then all
day like two things apart from the apart
from the obvious stuff for the All
Blacks that stood out for me was the
recovery defense like the the scramble
defense from the All Blacks was
exceptional and the second thing was the
breakdown work and I think the two guys
sirly flagged up um Kane and and Ry like
nine times out of 10 on the scramble D
recovery or the breakdown it was one or
both of those guys a couple of times
they were just awesome I don't know how
many times I saw Ireland take that long
ball to the edge bend the All Blacks on
the edge with that passive D Jimmy
spoken about and then Sam Kane just
flies at someone's inside hip makes a
cover tackle and someone gets over the
ball and either slows it down enough
that the all backs could rebuild their
defense between the 15s or turns it over
outright and wins the penalty like
those two guys were awesome and you know
we expect Ry to to do everything he does
week in week out but Sam Kane like I
know he's a guy that certainly in Europe
it seems like a guy that maybe doesn't
get that much love compared to previous
all black captains for you guys that
might be wrong but that's definitely the
way it's seen over here and you're right
yeah let me tell you now anybody that
thinks that Sam Kane is not a worldclass
player is a muppet he that guy is
absolutely awesome and back rows are all
about balance and I know I know in New
Zealand you guys have an abundance of
players with unbelievable power
physicality and rasle but you can't have
three guys all trying to do that in the
back row and what Sam Kane does is he
does every single bit of work around the
park so that Ry and whoever you guys
decide to play at six you've got an
abundance of ridiculous sixes can go and
do all the Razzle stuff go and make all
the carries and he he always there
blasting out rcks making cover tackles
slowing ball down to allow the guys to
go and do what they do and I just like
those guys maybe in the media and the
the fans don't always appreciate but you
can imagine the guys in the all black
team just love him I imagine Ari s just
must think the world of Sam Kane because
when he plays like that he lets the rest
of the back row and the rest of the pack
just go to work and do their do their
maybe more exciting stuff [__] it was
awesome boys right you're bang on again
and the last thing I wanted to mention
from that game is that the All Blacks
line out success rate for the whole
world cup not just this game 51 out of
52 they've only missed one line out this
whole tournament so that's a massive WP
to the Cody Taylor Dane CO's Tak AOS and
the line out callers white locks um
retalic frazelle at the front jumping
super quick um and obviously Jace Ryan
they've got their lineup plan R in Tech
I don't want to jinx them at all but man
one line line out out of 52 that's
incredible a for a true line out fan
like yourself yeah obviously love a line
out not the tallest of Timber but I like
to think I can analyze one with the best
of them but just on that point like also
against the Irish throw we were doing so
well to disrupt them and there was a
couple moments there where they were hot
on our line and we still got up and
competed and managed to just throw their
flow off a little bit I do wonder if
post game and hindsight's a great thing
but obviously the Irish turned down a
couple shots at goal that we would
expect them normally to take do wonder
if they just felt like they would
dominate the all backs at that set piece
area but I thought both our line out and
scrum were all over them so it was
interesting still around that 25 30
minute Mark when we'd already made a
nuisance of ourselves at set piece that
they were still going for the trial I
rate that that's a real southern
hemisphere type of mentality but of
course 6on missed one that we assumed he
would get but those other penalties as
well you back them all all day long so I
do wonder if now in hindsight they're
thinking maybe we should have taken the
three because the four pack for New
Zealand was so on yeah that's an
interesting point you you sort of forget
about that um when you look back at the
game but like any one of those K go over
and um could have been a different
result like you say but we'll get to the
next game cuz I think this was a bit of
an underrated one of the weekend England
V FG and snake you'll be proud of your
English boys here I I was really
impressed and especially that first sort
of 20 30 minutes they came to play they
giving the ball some air it was it was
nice to
see yeah I think Nick Mullins on ITV on
on the coverage in the UK summ this game
up perfectly in kickoff he said that
there's maybe never been a game in the
history of English rugby that they've
needed to win more the the last 18
months in English rugby has been
terrible Lads I mean we've lost four
clubs four domestic clubs have gone into
liquidation the the the national
performances and results have been at
you know pretty much an all-time low
attendances overall interest confidence
in in the game in the UK has taken an
absolute bashing and for the fans like
just to get some confidence back and
some enjoyment back out of rugby this
was such a huge game the guys would have
been under so much pressure going into
this and they they got the result done
and like you said Jim I thought they
were for the first 20 minutes I was
really really impressed with um with how
played I thought I thought Marcus Smith
added a lot to that England backline
compared to the Samoa performance I
think I mentioned in the preview England
desperately needed something more in
that middle zone between the 22s in in
their attack shape and he really adds
that as a second ball player you know
surle said it in the in the show last
week he's a bit like Damien McKenzie he
he sees space so well his instincts are
so good you can see he sometimes he
doesn't even think about his decision he
just reacts on Instinct and his
instincts are so good um and he moves
the ball to space quickly I think
sometimes in England we see the space
and we go oh okay we'll let the forwards
go once more and then we'll get the
space but at International test match
level that extra phase can be enough for
defense to recover he's not like that he
moves the ball straight away when he
sees the space um and he's one of the
only guys in the England squad who I
would say is like genuine triple threat
on the ball in terms of run pass kick
you look all the world class teams they
all have those guys who offer that
genuine Triple Threat ball in hand you
you think of you will Jordan dmac for
the All Blacks dupon James low for
Ireland I think is a good example Vala
even at the back for South Africa like
they're guys that especially when they
pick the ball up in the back
field they can offer that run pass kick
which just makes it so much harder to
defend and in terms of what England
needed for Fiji I thought it was a
really really good selection and an
aggressive selection for England which
was nice my my concern now is moving
forward and obviously we'll touch on the
preview is can he play for England
against South Africa after the sort of
contestable kick air raid that they put
on France you know he's they had so much
success against France and Marcus
Smith's not a specialist fullback he's
not a big guy and that is where Freddy
Stewart's really good so that's I think
the will be the question in camping in
the English media this week is can we
keep Marcus back there to keep offering
more to our attack in that Midfield
Zone yeah it's going to be an
interesting I I think they're going to
go Fredy because of those points you
suggest but it was good to see Marcus
Smith out there he jez he was tough he
had to be he was coughing he was getting
steam by rrra getting high shots from
hosi and M it was good stuff good to see
how tough the the kid was because you're
right he can't play but in the game I
felt like England were all over them um
and then there was just a patch of of
sort of 5 to 10 minutes where Fiji just
go bang bang and all of a sudden the
game is even again we're like holy okay
here we go like Fiji are on here they
had all the momentum and then the game
got really close Fiji had a chance to
win it at the death um but it looked
like they just sort of went right into
their shell again like they were just
playing off nine they they were playing
off no speed they just it looked like
they were so afraid to lose the game
that it ended up costing them no one was
willing to make a risk to make the play
so that faar of failure in the back end
of the game I felt like it cost um FG
but what do you make of fg's performance
Surly yeah like you mentioned there I
guess like those pressure points in the
game like the start and then the end
which is where the good teams really
stand up I feel like they went to sleep
a little whereas when the game got into
like that flow towards the start of the
second half middle of the second half
they kind of woke up then and played
some really good footy and that's often
when teams that struggle on the biggest
stages do play their best code because
that isn't the high pressure areas but I
I love watching them play This World
Cup's been a massive success for them
just to make the quarterfinal I was GED
to see their coach he's um he's not
coaching them past this year so he's
decided that he's not going to be
involved which is a bit sad just cuz I
think technically he's been amazing for
them but also in terms of like culture
and connection like he took them back to
Fiji and they seem like such a close
group you know you got guys with family
members passing away that are choosing
to stay on like obviously they felt that
connection to the team as well so no
doubt that job will be in high demand
maybe a Jimmy Marshall to come in there
and help take the lads to another level
but what about the whole um dancing
France preview crew there we oh there we
go there we go snaky can run a fine
tooth comb through the goal kicking
tickers as well you can do the
line yeah that would be massive massive
I was actually proud of England for this
one like I feel like they it was a game
for them where they had everything to
lose like everyone was just praying for
the upset to get on Fiji and then put
that final boot into England and it's
almost like England won and now
everyone's like oh like yeah you expect
England to beat Fiji and it's like no
you weren't saying that last week so I
do think we need to give England their
flowers cuz this is the best they looked
for a 60 to 70 minute period And I
genuinely do think that they are a
finals footy team and I think we'll see
another lift from them this week and
just yeah they're just fueled by the
hate aren't they like every press
conference they're just every all
whoever's up there says oh you didn't
expect us to be here and here we are and
you can tell it's really United them as
well so it's going to be interesting
this week but overall takeaway was just
well done to Fiji maybe a bridge too far
but the growth that they're going to get
from this is just massive and hopefully
they another side like we mentioned just
need quality big games like imagine imag
them in the rugby Championship that
would be massive I hope it does happen
because it it would be a massive growth
for their game I feel like they're good
enough to be there they've already been
in Australia I think that'd be always a
challenge for the All Blacks in South
Africa as well so um yeah it would be
awesome hopefully that can happen but I
do remember speaking about um the
breakdown in this preview around um bti
here and how they
were how they were rewarded at that
breakdown and I felt like it when either
way some of them were um really clear
pictures where he got and they played
off him and some of them they got pinged
and really put them under pressure they
were huge momentum swings every time he
went for those balls and um I don't
think it was really strong one way or
the other and probably hence why the
game was so
even yeah they were into him as well he
like you could tell it was part of their
game plan they weren't going to back
down to him physically and every chance
they got they tried to raffle his
feathers he's not a bloke cold want to
take on and a buff but hey good on the
the English like I thought Courtney lws
was outstanding as well man he put his
body through the ringer he's a like one
of these guys like he's always been a
great footballer but he's been so in
and- out right and it seems like now
he's finally getting the credit he
deserves as well cuz he's like one of
those loose WS that you could imagine
playing in a New Zealand team he's a
great footballer yeah he's he's one of
those guys where he's struggled a lot
with injury like he misses so much of
the Premiership season due to injury but
Surly man you're right I flagged up him
as the outstanding performer in the game
and he so often is for England like I
remember the last Lions tour like he
basically didn't play for nine months
came in and he was the Lions player at
the series and I think the England team
at the moment he probably is the one guy
who would been in in the mix for a world
15 he is our one world class operator
and like I said he he is one of those
guys who just often is not in those
conversations because he spends you know
six months of a year on the on the
medical table and it is just the case
but it's part of the way he plays isn't
necessarily you can't throw yourself
into body into collisions like that and
not expect to have to have your shoulder
glued back on twice a
year yeah and it is hard to believe that
England are the last team from the
northern hemisphere in the in the Rugby
World Cup so um yeah well done snake you
called it from the start but we'll get
to the next game France versus South
Africa wowe now this was a game France's
start was incredible what' you make of
this one suy
yeah after that all blacks Island game I
thought there's no way another game
could come close to this and if that
game didn't exist then you might well be
talking about this France South Africa
game as one of the greatest
quarterfinals ever right like I was just
stoked to see South Africa Shar in that
first 40 and play footy like we've said
this whole time they've got some
talented backs they can move the ball
and they weren't afraid to do that it's
like they took on the French rle
themselves with that starting lineup
with faf and hundre on the bench they
kind of showed their hand that they were
going to play and jeez that first 40
minutes like I was messaging all my
mates been like if you're not watching
this game of footy you need to get in
front of a TV aset because it was like
you were glued to the seat had
everything charge down which look maybe
he did leave early but we maybe we'll
get to that but it was just everything
you didn't expect to happen was
happening it was some Elite playmaking
from both sides the second half kind of
tightened up a bit and it was more the
South Africa you'd come to expect but it
was still bloody interesting to watch as
well and then right down to the last
play you weren't sure who was going to
win the French I can't work out what
they're doing at the end of that game
like it wasn't they weren't playing for
penalties but they weren't playing
either like the ball was going to their
props and locks and they were walking
into contact like clearly they were
gassed but you just wonder if like an
Interac with someone there just like one
of their Elite game drivers would have
got them in the right position but I
think in the end South Africa deserved
to win and they got the win but there
wasn't a lot between it and again we'll
touch on Dupont I'm sure but man what a
freak like geez like we've seen some
world class performances over the
weekend and his was Second To None what
a footballer yeah mate you're so right
about that last passage the the French
looks so gas like you compare that last
face for them and compare it to sort of
the first five phases where everything
was just at such high Tempo they're
playing at such fast speeds Dupont was
seeing everything you're right that
guy's incredible I I don't think anyone
has the spatial awareness of awareness
of where everyone is on the field like
he does for a nine it's it's quite a
hard skill because you're often thinking
about ball first receiver but his
awareness of the back field and where
his Wingers are he's always finding kick
space as soon as there some um geez he
is so special like his vision is
incredible but their speed when they
play with speed they're so hard to stop
but um you're right in that last those
last phases there wasn't much speed
going on even Dupont look Gass um they
just had they didn't really throw
anything at them they just had no energy
to which was a shame because I would
have loved to see France go through um
especially with the for the home nation
and I'm sure a lot of people were hoping
Ireland were going to go through for
sort of the similar reason sounds like
most of the fans over there are Irish
and an irland France final really
probably would have been the organizer's
dream but um you can't uh no one gets
the easy walk through so obviously All
Blacks I think all blacks South Africa
we'll get to that
soon it's all about to happen um but
this game was incredible I was really
impressed with South Africa's line speed
I you know I'm a line speed man and I
just thought they put the French under
so much pressure and they didn't have
the time and space to get it to the edge
um forced heaps of Errors which is
pretty uncharacteristic from the French
and created opportunities off it and a
lot of those opportunities also came off
their contestable game like you
mentioned snake um the French didn't
handle that very well and it probably
cost them the game so what' you make of
it snake you haven't even got to you yet
yeah jeez your boys not left me a lot to
uh get suck into sur's pretty much just
read off my off my play sheet um I think
give us some analysis come hey boys look
all I'll say is R's 100% been listening
to the Pod because we've been asking
we've been asking for weeks for them to
play just a bit more you know I'm not
expecting them to turn up and throw
their DNA out the window and be island
or the All Blacks or Fiji but when they
Nam the team like [__] I was buzzing to
watch this game because they started
kobus and leok as the halfbacks that's
an aggressive Choice compared to faf and
hundre which would have been their other
option so straight away and then the 5-3
split on the bench as well which we
don't often see South Africa use which
is funny to say because it's it's pretty
much the standard bench split for most
teams but when when that team Sheet came
out which was obviously after we
recorded last week um because razi
delayed delayed the team announcement
for the first time in the comp um once
that team came out I thought oh they
might actually try and do something a
bit different here and and they they did
like Jim said especially in the first
half like they were pulling the ball out
of that first pod and challenging France
in that Midfield where the two big
Frenchy props often end up and I think
it helped them get a lot of that game
onine success but the other thing it did
was it split the field so they they they
broke the Midfield portion of the
defense and it gave them the option to
hit those bombs and those kicks off nine
to the corners and like you guys can say
any everyone can say what they want
about Razzi but he has turned this South
African team into the
most connected and resilient group of
players on the planet like in my notes
before I I I'd written down that South
Africa needed a big start to to win this
game because they had to kill the French
momentum and they had to shut the crowd
up and they had the exact opposite
France had the [__] dream start and
for the first 15 20 minutes like those
South African Lads on the field would
have felt like they were playing against
880,000 people but it just brings them
closer together and anything that just
requires basic work cre effort they were
better than France in this game the kick
Chase was awesome you spoke about Colby
on the charge down like all that is is
just effort and and concentration it it
takes no skill yeah yeah he's quick but
there's three or four guys on the pitch
that could make that distance up for
both teams it's just they they just
everything that they have to do to win
games of rugby from a mentality point of
view they're willing to do for each
other the bench had a massive impact I
thought South Africa's bench was was a
lot lot better than France's but I think
South Africa basically win this game
because they were the more emotionally
mature team in in the big moments in the
last 20 minutes especially and I think a
lot of that speaking to guys that that I
know have been in and around the squads
or or no guys in the squads like that is
all down to rasi apparently he's massive
on culture massive on connection and
work rate between the guys and you can
see they buy in like you see the footage
after the game of them hugging each
other and like those guys love each
other and they love going out and
working for each other and I thought um
I thought Ed Beth was unbelievable in
this game I think every single World Cup
the guy gets better and better he yeah
he was absolutely awesome in this game
he was the guy I flagged up as my my key
performer obviously got the try but set
peace time physicality obviously had his
little rest for his hiia which Jimmy
maybe you can decide whether was pre
you're the coach what do you think of
that he had his little uh he had his
little water break and came back on and
started melting people again yeah very
interesting and it was pretty pretty
obvious to me what was going on with
their subs but um he's obviously
mentioned that he wouldn't ever fake hi
but I don't think it had to be an hi I
think there's definitely plans for fake
injuries in that game like um you don't
bring a reserve hooker on for your
captain and then 10 minutes later your
your starting hooker goes down so you
can get on another fresh Loosey Steph
DET toit comes on ready for that last um
10 minutes obviously they don't do it
every week they knew the the um the
situation of this game and how how
important it was so theyve I just think
they've used they haven't used they've
bent the rules or dodgy bent the rules
um very very cleverly I I that's what I
love about Rie is that he does do things
outside the box I mean I don't think you
get a bigger dick play than calling a
mark off a off a a scram off a mark in
the 22 never seen that before could have
easily backfired like he said in his
press conference like you don't see all
these um ideas that he has because some
of them don't work but when they do work
like that um you're catching a mark in
the 22 you're calling a scrum you get a
scrum penalty and you look like a
absolute Guru but man it it is just like
something that not many coaches think
about so I think it's really cool to see
a coach just being so out the box and
out the gate and yeah I think he's I
think he's done an outstanding job with
that crew but what do you think of that
um you mentioned itth there Snake what
do you think of that intercept SL
knockdown which is obviously a big
talking point at the
moment yeah there was a few over the
weekend and there's been a couple during
the tournament hasn't there I I don't
have issues with the decision either way
I think all that the fans but more
importantly like the players want is
consistency on these decisions and I
know it's a a cliche point to make in
terms of when you're talking about any
referee in decision but there has to be
a clearer specification set up for what
a deliberate knock on is whether they go
really harsh and they say okay if it's
anything with one hand that's a
deliberate knockdown or if they they
they can Define it in another way but
they have to be more specific on how
less interpretation for the individual
referee because also it protects the
referee if you make the rule clearer
then people can't get stuck into the
referees on social media after the game
because the referee can just you know
say in his match right up law 1.17 a
deliber knock on is when anyone slaps
the ball with one hand and the law the
law at the moment is if you're making a
genuine attempt to catch the ball so but
what's a genuine but what what's a
genuine attempt though that's so that's
so down to interpretation don't you
think because it's basically then the
referee has to decide was he actually
trying to catch it do do you I
everything's going to come down to an
interpretation at the end I I I quite
like the rule as it is I think the thing
with zabeth is obviously um Ben o Keef
has ruled that it's gone backwards which
has saved him otherwise it wouldn't have
probably been a genuine attempt cuz he
was very loose with his action Aaron
Smith his one was a bit different cuz he
just stuck his arm out didn't he wasn't
actually looking to catch it it looked
like he was more just looking to get in
the passing Lane he wasn't looking to
slap it down either so I'm not sure if
that's a that's a yellow card I think
that was just a penalty person I thought
that was harsh to give him a card but
the it's aeth one's interesting once
once it's rolled back it's obviously
can't be a deliberate slap down or um
cuz it's play on so that was a real
unique situation but obviously one which
is always going to be controversial for
any referee and um I do think one thing
on the referees like I felt like the
teams who ended up getting a lot of the
results were the ones who were
complaining less or less into the
referee I thought the French were all
over Ben oef that game every decision uh
Dupont which is pretty uncharacteristic
for him was throwing his hands up
shaking his head slowing his own ball
down um there's a lot of energy going
towards the referee and same with the
fijians I felt like they spent a lot of
time complaining and I even hearing them
talk they all all feeling sorry for
themselves around how they're treated or
unconscious bias I don't think it is
unconscious bias I just think they don't
react as well to decisions like others
like anyone would look at that all black
team um they got a couple of yellow
cards um penalty try I mean they I think
the Aaron Smith one was harsh but the
other one was obviously Fair it's part
of the rules if you give away a penalty
try you get a yellow card which is I
still think is a incredibly harsh rule
but what I loved about the All Blacks
was just how they handled all these
decisions looked like they just straight
away went on to the next job no one was
complaining um and just had that real
next task Focus which I reckon cost a
couple of other teams because like Beno
Keef said in his episode he's probably
going to go through the game and he find
30 decisions either way that um have
gone wrong for each side so I think it's
a good mentality if you go into a game
knowing that there's going to be 30
decisions go against you you just sort
of tick them off every bad call instead
of getting really wound up about them so
um you're going to see on social media
probably 30 examples of decisions for
each team which could have gone either
way and and that's just part of the game
and it's part of refering that's why i'
never want to do it because these guys
are doing an incredible job they're
doing their best and that's um always
can really ask for cuz it's such a hard
G what do you make of that suly the r
it's it's a great call and the saddest
thing like obviously being know keeth
got announced for a semi-final and I
went to mention it on my story and just
be like unreal well done and he's
blocked mentions because that's how much
Flack he's coping online like it's so
sad right these guys are just humans
doing their job and of course when
you're on the losing Side Of The Ledger
you're going to look for things that
went wrong like you said I I put it down
to leadership arican kisi like we spoke
about Russy before like he's probably
the best leader in arguably World sport
at the moment right the way he's he
talks every credit after every game he
puts back to the country of South Africa
they're doing it for the fans and I
think Russy made a good point in his
press conference yesterday he said like
they're like the yin and yang right like
Russy rattles some Fe feathers pregame
but then kisi manages everything so well
in game that you can't not like the
South Africans Ry can almost say
whatever he wants in a press conference
and he's incredibly intelligent and he
words it all really well but he does
plant a few seeds and then you've got
kisi on the field just oh yes sir like
agreeing with everything and and the way
he handles himself so yeah full credit
to the South Africans and also full
credit to Beno Keefe it's awesome to see
him get a semifinal this week because he
is one of the top Rifts in the game so
he he deserves it I agree and it's
interesting you mentioned that he's
blocked mentions because that my people
were coming at my inbox but obviously
having him on the podcast they going
through all
the posts and things on Tik Tok French
fans were abusing me for some reason so
I felt like I was a referee for half a
day after that game so in the trenches
Jimmy the men of the
people just coughing up for Ben but
anything to take the pressure off that
man um looking forward to I hope he has
a good game this weekend I don't want
another weekend of dropping it but um
yeah good on him for getting another
semi-final and who do you think will
referee the final obviously um set up
for Barnes if Barnes England don't make
it but yeah I think it'll be Barnes I I
noticed before Russy was talking about
this is the fourth time they've had Ben
O'Keefe now and whether that could go in
their favor or against them because he
hasn't ried an English game so that'll
be interesting but yeah I think it's
going to be Wayne Barnes that's the ref
that I want to be fair I reckon like a
few people are going on about like a
couple calls that he made on the weekend
but I thought he was really good and it
was more his TMO trying to get into his
air and convince him that it should have
been more so I I think Wayne is probably
the best referee in the world at the
moment he just has like an ability to
think so slowly in high pressure
situations and look at it logically and
try and I think he tries to think like a
player and and how he would want it to
be interpreted so yeah I have no
problems if it's Wayne Barnes I think
he's best guy but obviously England
would have to lose for that to happen so
yeah and I think Wayne barns has been
the best for the last sort of eight
years like his experience um how he
handles those pressure moments 2007 mate
Jesus even that game like if you go back
and watch that game he did an incredible
job and speaking to all the referees
like he actually managed that game
really well he got one decision wrong
and and the country still hates him for
it which is just the life of a ref which
is a shame but man what a what a review
man that is the most in-depth review
we've ever done so well done lad you
guys are all on fire I'll give you a
quick update on my fantasy I know a lot
of people love this segment some people
even fast forward it incredibly which is
a bit sad but um my week on fantasy I'm
up to
151st in the world so I'm in Striking
Distance now I didn't feel like I had a
great week but it was a very tough week
like I mentioned I didn't think anyone
would get over 80 points only the French
hoer got 80 points exactly um will
Jordan my captain got 41 which was about
um on par with most of the scores across
the board 40ish was a reasonable score
for the round but this is going to be
the week I'm only up to ninth in the W
lead leg water lad League like I said
last week um the guys in front of me are
absolute gurus and using using a little
bit of copy and paste which is fair
enough as long as we're all climbing up
the world rankings I'm happy but um this
week is going to be the massive one I'm
thinking there's going to be some bigger
scores triple captains on the line this
weekend so um as I go through this
preview I will share my thoughts but
there's a guy coming back from
suspension who I think will be my triple
Captain this weekend you might be able
to work that one out but we'll get to
the first game semifinals footy
Argentina vers All Blacks didn't expect
this to be the matchup at the start of
the tournament but Argentina versus All
Blacks what do you going
snake
unless unless there's red
guards which hey is a genuine chance you
know we've seen over the last couple
years early red cards in big test match
games of rugby big big finals
domestically as well they do happen but
unless there's red cards I can't really
see any upset in either game this final
I think the ABS I mentioned last week
they're just peing at the right time I
think they've already got
any kind of bad performances any being
undercooked any low confidence they got
it out of their system before the World
Cup against South Africa and in that
round one game against France and now I
just think they're cooking on gas and I
don't really see any you know in my
preview notes I thought oh you know
maybe I can talk about Argentina's set
piece they've got a great set piece but
all black set piece has been fantastic
at the tournament since round one as
well
so unless unless there's a real shocker
with a with a red carard or some really
bad ill discipline I don't I don't see
where Argentina get into the game well I
even think back to the England Argentina
game at the start of the tournament
Argent England get a red card and
they're still far too good for Argentina
so like it's it's hard to make a case
for Argentina to beat the All Blacks
here um I'm not convinced on their day I
think the All Blacks are going to have a
bit of a field day out wide um they
don't put teams Under Pressure like a
South Africa wall potentially the
following week which is going to be oh
some challenge but I do think that all
blacks are going to be far too good in
this I'm thinking 30 points um which is
a big call for a semi-final but I do
think we'll come out of this game and
boys will probably get an opportunity to
get an early sub um and hopefully
prepare for the final but what are you
saying Surly you you're I know you're
big Argentina man as well you love Messi
Pablo yeah I do love Pablo I was GED cuz
you know the two players I wanted to see
clash in this one Pablo and Coy they're
both not in the mix I would have loved
to have seen a repeat yeah definitely
technical save the money on the on the
fines to World rugby but my only worry
coming into this one was perhaps a bit
of complacency like obviously last week
such a big win and if you rewind the
clock back we bet South Africa last year
probably to save Ian Foster and then the
week after the boys actually got tripped
up by Argentina and Christ church so I
thought maybe there could be a bit of
patry coming into play there but hearing
the lads speak at the press conference
like that's the exact first thing that
Dane Kohl's and Jason Ryan brought up
was like much like Ireland we owe these
guys one and it just seems like they're
so fueled on that type of mindset at the
moment which I think is really proving
really well for these this all black
team so yeah I expect us to be too
strong as well I just think we'll have
way too many weapons across the peddock
but in a way I feel like making a
semifinal is just a win for Argentina
and I think that's why we saw them react
the way they did last week so um like
full credit to them I don't yeah I'd
love to see us win by 30 my that's my
dream for this is 50 minutes the game's
done we can roll the bench get dmac and
and Finlay and all those guys on so we
can rest those big bodies we've got a
slightly shorter turnaround into this
game so that could prove to be huge and
then we'll get an extra day leading into
the final but Argentina they're one of
those sides we saw on the weekend if if
they can get a random try then they can
really kick on from that as well so yeah
I'd be saying 13 plus but maybe more in
that kind of 20 Zone because I do expect
us to roll the subs and maybe you know
Argentina score A couple late but you
would like to think that the All Blacks
do this one fairly comfortably it's
probably more the process right and the
and how they look in doing it rather
than the the actual contest on the score
line in a way yeah I think speaking or
hearing them boys speak after that game
gave me a lot of confidence going into
this game cuz you're right around
potentially taking this one um you're
not not mentally getting up with the
same emotion as you have the last couple
but um obviously a lot of the group were
in the Japan Rugby World Cup where they
absolutely annihilated Island and one of
their best performances I think was like
42 points put on an absolute clinic and
England weren't playing that well at the
time and then um come to the semi-final
just look absolutely shocked with the um
intensity that England brought to them
and they lost that semi-final so I think
they learned from that and a lot of the
group is still playing so I don't think
they'll be going to this game complacent
and um they've named their strongest
side uh that they they believe um
obviously there's a few people who with
different opinions um but yeah I I think
the or would be too good what are you
going snake you usually round us up yeah
I think I can see it being New Zealand
by 10 to 15 but then a last 20 minute
blowout that just changes the whole
outlook of the score I think if it gets
to 60 minutes and Argentina are chasing
two scores and they have to go after the
game and start playing from Deep trying
to get the two tries to get themselves
back in the game it can backfire on them
and they can get stung you know let's
say they can see two three tries in the
last couple of minutes it just changes
the whole outlook of the game it'll
definitely be a test match for for 50 60
minutes I just I don't think they have
the same quality on the bench as the ABS
they don't have the same Fitness levels
and although they've improved through
the tournament they haven't improved
through the tournament the same level
the All Blacks have the All Blacks now
look a different team to to the team we
saw coming into the tournament I I just
think everything's stacked in New
Zealand's favor and exactly like you boy
said I I think the guys in that camp now
I I don't have any concerns about
complacency here from these guys I think
they got the bit between their teeth now
and if anything I think that Island game
is actually just the opposite I think
it's just fuel on the fire now like that
Island game if anything's just going to
have more confident they'll been
believing more in what they're doing
believing more in each other um and and
I just see New Zealand's performance is
staying high now for the rest of the
tournament nice I like it and what do
you make of the side sirly obviously
to's back like I mentioned um har on
Leicester obviously had a great game
every time he's put the Jersey on on
hasn't even made a spot on the bench but
like I said I thought Anton made a
really good impact coming off the bench
as well um but looking forward to seeing
to back obviously there's still a lot of
calls around royard why is royard not
playing and takaho comes in for kl's as
well white lck gets a start so there's a
few subtle changes but majority of the
group stays the same what do you make of
it where's your thoughts yeah the the
TOA one I think that was the one that I
predicted was going to be the one change
to the 23 like you mentioned there's
been a couple adjustments around the
bench but I F he's kind of showing that
he is a loyal guy and he picks he he
backs his guys that he picks and TOA
started every big game apart from the
one on the weekend where he supposedly
had a couple too many and and paid the
price for it it is Harsh on Leicester I
think the way like you said Anton's
playing you're either starting in on the
wing or you're not making the 23 um I do
Wonder as well if Mark is just a little
bit better defensively and has a bit of
a better aerial game for kick defusion
and they're looking towards South Africa
or Argentina who like to kick the ball
as well so I wonder if they see him as
more of that well-rounded player but I
do like what Lester brings us he's like
a ninth forward he's a big body he has
the ability to break tackles and things
like that as well but at the same time
Mark has such a high work rate he's
dangerous around rucks as well he's more
that slippery elusive type of character
and I think overall he's probably earned
that spot and he obviously hasn't done
enough Wrong by the team to lose it so I
guess you see the mindset there I wasn't
sure if you were alluding to him before
as you triple kept him but I and he
could come out and have a pretty big
performance and score a couple tries um
and then yeah those those locks I guess
they're just rotating to keep time off
off pins for a few of those boys like
that was a physical game they're not the
youngest of lads in terms of Brody and
Sam so I think that's a smart play and
then the hooker one's interesting for me
maybe kl's has a niggle or something I'm
not too sure but I thought Dan was
really good on the weekend whereas
coming into this tournament I would have
had Taho on in that start in that bench
roll sorry so I don't know as a player
if he's not injured it's probably
frustrating for him because you're
giving an opportunity for a guy to play
their way in but there's obviously some
type of mindset around it and I'd be
predicting kl's to come off the bench in
the
Final Mate I like where your heads at
and yes it was Mark T who I'm looking to
Triple cap then it's either him or will
Jordan I think one of those guys are
going to go big I just need to make sure
I get the right guy and what else I'm
doing is my my fantasy side as I'm
basically using my five all black
players that you're allowed all in the
backline I just think it's going to be
one of those days for the all black
backs um against this Argentinian
Argentinian D um that they're going to
rack up some big scores so it's going to
cost me the likes to get I'm not going
to be able to have Ary which is um he's
a back tough because yeah he's
potentially he's he obviously top scored
for the All Blacks in the weekend with
66 points and even someone like Scott
Barrett I'd love to have this weekend
but you're only L five so I'm going to
go the Jordy
Rico um Richie will Jordan and Mark toir
combo and hopefully the All Blacks have
an absolute feel down the back so that's
where I'm going fantasy players
hopefully you enjoy that and um don't
copy me and yeah that could be a smoke
screen mate you could be releasing fake
all black teams here much like the All
Blacks Camp is to throw off any scent of
some leaks mate yeah well we'll get to
the next game England vers South Africa
this is where you come and
snake what are you going here I'm
interested in your
opinion look boys I in sport I always
love a Revenge match narrative and for
England could this be the 2019 World Cup
final Revenge
match um you're always a chance you're
always a chance Lads especially in big
games I think there's there is enough
big game experience and and key game
drivers for England that they are they
are a they are a chance I was going to
say a genuine chance but they're an
outside chance for sure the issue for
England with this matchup is like so
many of England's strengths are just
neutralized by South Africa's strengths
so I don't you know you think of
England's strength at the moment like
kicking game set piece they go pretty
good defensively they're pretty
aggressive and physic but all of those
things South Africa do at a world class
level may be better so I again I'm
struggling to see a way that England get
in this game unless we're talking you
know a red card or something crazy which
I'm not going to write off um but
similar to what I said about the ABS l i
I don't think South Africa are going to
be complacent like I mentioned the the
place that Russ's got these Lads to
mentally like they'll have one goal now
and that's winning the World Cup and
they will 100% be in the in the mental
head space of plowing through England to
set up a final with what they they
presume will be the All Blacks um so
look there a chance it's knockout game I
obviously mentioned last week I I felt a
bit split because I really loved that
fij team and I wanted them to do well
but this week I'm like if the boys get
this done I will be buzzing I will be
absolutely over the moon that World Cup
Final in 2019 was such a tough watch
especially after that semi-final
performance against ulad it was really
really disappointing so look there a
chance it's it's knockout rugby
but I I am struggling to see a an area
of the game where England have the upper
hand what do you boys reckon yeah I'm
I'm with you I agree with everything you
say but I do think that style of footy
that both of them are really good at
does bring it into a closer match and
then you are relying on a couple of
moments it might be a bounce of a ball
might be a decision which it you know it
always comes down to one or two
decisions when you look back at it um so
I I do think the England's ability to
just be able to go up in threes and um
match them potentially at set piece time
and physically so um I was impressed
with like gez carry and ear were um into
it in the weekend I feel like they'll be
right into the South Africans and the
South Africans won't enjoy that so I do
I actually had South Africa down by 20
but um I feel like I'm talking myself
into a much closer game and
um it wouldn't surprise me as much if
england beat South Africa as it would if
Argentina beat the All Blacks I think
this will be a closer match but I do
think
realistically um South Africa will be
too good but where you going suly yeah
I'm more in that South Africa too good
but not by a lot I think England are
great finals side and they always rise
to the occasion and like we said that
the games appear to be quite similar
I'll be interested I think they'll go
with faf and hundre to start just oh
yeah but I don't think you need to fight
the French Flair straight away I think
they can roll straight into that kind of
10-man kicking game style of rugby and
just take England on at that themselves
so I think they'll start with both of
those but I would like to see them res
it up again and play a bit of footy to
start with but yeah I have South Africa
kind of in that I don't know 10 to 15
margin maybe a little less cuz I I do
think for 60 odd minutes this is going
to be a heck of a game it's going to be
physical man there's going to be some
big collisions in those for packs and
through that Midfield so I'm actually
excited to watch this game I do think
South Africa will win but it's more the
way that they go about it and it could
take a big toll on them if they get the
win here because there's going to be
some bruised bodies like this is the
more physical and mentally demanding
matchup of the two I just think South
Africa like they they talk now like
they're so United they're playing for
their Nation like it doesn't matter who
they come up against they're going to be
on mentally so you'd back them to get
the win but yeah never ride off the
English in a Finals game we learned that
lesson like you mentioned did we were
and a shame Rie hasn't named his side um
this week but shout out to Rie for
naming the English side for us so it's
good to a little bit of a up there only
changes um Stewart to pack and um yeah
he's a he's a good man he's had good
case in those um press conferences he's
a little bit like Eddie Joneses but
obviously getting the results so and
shout out to Eddie for staying with
Australia um suly I know your prediction
of um Steven Lam was um yeah close but
it went close it went close I noticed
there was a couple questions there in
the P press conference he just didn't
respond to it it was so good they were
like can you confirm he's like yep and
they're like so you'll be coaching in
2027 and he just goes on I was like he
hardly the most convincing but when you
listen to him talk like now that it's
all happened right like going Young into
a World Cup right before the World Cup
not the smartest move but now when he
speaks about it for building towards
2027 and like the state of Australian
rugby he can convince you that it was
the right thing to do so salesman isn't
he time so it's going to be interesting
like this next two years I don't know
what the odds are for him to make it to
2027 I don't think I believe him but if
he turns this around by say
2025 then he looks like a genius so it
could really go either way
yeah 2027 it's going to be interesting
to see where they're at
and um do they have to qualify now
because do you have to qualify if you
don't make the quarters or how does it
work no no no I think it's top three of
the groups go through automatic I
think don't even qualify Eddie's issue
for the 2027 World Cup Lads will be if
he's got any assistant coaches left I
think that would be big problem he might
get there but he might have no one to
run his Packer his backline they're all
turning on him hey they're all turning
on him one of them said that the his
Club trainings in Europe is harder than
the way iddie was running them I like
holy
smokes yeah right interesting times but
boys what a preview what a review um
enjoy this weekend of foot it's going to
be another absolute classic and I'm look
forward to our final preview show next
weekend is hopefully we preview on All
Blacks South Africa or England um for
snake um final so looking forward to it
appreciate your time as always
Lads
the say it
snake oh up the
ABS